one of the things that I'm excited about
with IMAX enhanced is that if you can't
see in the theater it's the next best
thing
Marvel's first priority is always tell
the best story and those immersive
Technologies help us do that
[Music]
the fans go to the theater they see it
in the biggest loudest screen they can
find but then they come home and they
want to experience it again with IMAX
enhanced we can finally make available
to people this thing they've been asking
for for a long time the idea is to honor
that movie movies play very differently
in in a smaller space when you're not in
a commercial environment what you're
trying to achieve that IMAX enhanced
helps is carrying that intention from
the filmmakers all the way through so
that when I'm sitting at home on my
couch a scene plays emotionally and from
a storytelling perspective the same way
it does if you're sitting in a movie
theater
foreign we've done a lot of work with a
variable aspect ratio in IMAX the idea
was 240 to one I know the movie gets a
bit bigger a bit more immersive
what's critical is the emotional intent
of that storytelling moment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one there was a scene where we were
inside the spaceship and walks up the
stairs and we hid a transition to the
larger format as we passed a bulkhead
and so because on the a side we wanted
it to be
constrained you're inside this tight
little spaceship and then on the B side
we saw this big Celestial pad floating
in outer space and we wanted to see this
big epic moment so James had us hide
that transition in there and it's it's a
subtle thing but it's really cool
you don't make a gimmicky you're not
chasing the technology you're saying
like no this is cool let's figure out a
way to use it to tell a better story so
it is truly more image area that you're
seeing it is creatively planned for it
is not an afterthought it is actually
designed into the shooting of the movie
and our fan base in particular they're
not casual viewers it's an experience
for them they want to recreate that
theatrical experience in the home
it's not just an exhibitor format we're
Partners so we're taking our filming
we're working together to adjust things
specifically to maximize the format and
when we went into the home we did the
same thing making creative choices that
honor the creative choices we made
theatrically but now we've got a bigger
palette we've got more colors in our
paint box what do we do with those right
[Music]
you have so many Incredible characters
in the Marvel Universe
we need to know which superhero would
you be Iron Man he can fly he's a
billionaire and he's a genius I I don't
know why I always had a soft spot for
Ant-Man Paul Rudd right what's not
polite exactly now the sexiest man of
the year apparently I'm just saying
[Music]